the A to Z of isms minimalism for some
people minimalism just means not owning
any staff it's a lifestyle choice it
means owning few possessions living in
largely empty space and even eating
minimalist food no chips for the
minimalists they own shiny white tablets
shop at little gray stores and don't
have enough black plastic chairs the sum
it's to do with architecture and for
others it's a musical movement in fact
minimalism is a philosophy with roots
and branches in many places the word
minimalism first turns up in 1965 in an
article by British philosopher Richard
Walheim who wrote about artists with
minimal art content this negative
description was turned into a positive
by minimalist artists they saw
minimalism as a kind of pure art to
quote the minimalist painter frank
stella what you see is what you see this
isn't art that copies something real a
person's face a nice horse or tries to
depict a feeling a minimalist art object
is itself and nothing else
all minimalism is in part a reaction in
the case of minimalist architecture it's
a reaction to decoration to ornament and
to fuss minimalist buildings are simple
and minimalist architects like Ludwig
Mies van der Rohe ER and mayor Lynn
create structures full of light and
space their work can be summed up in van
der Rohe s famous statement that less is
more minimalist gurus like Mary Kondo
believe in decluttering but say it's not
about knowing what to throw out it's
knowing what to keep a lot of minimalism
can appear harsh and inhuman the
exception is minimalistic music
pioneered by composers like Philip Glass
minimus music features repetitions
simple patterns and phase shifting the
movement of a repeating item to create
an arresting effect
despite the often austere simplicity of
the music or because of it many
minimalistic pieces of music are
profoundly moving and deeply emotional
minimalism is in part a reaction to the
increasingly busy and loud world around
us artists and consumers alike have
reacted against the
laughter and chaos of life and art and
created many disparate forms of
minimalism sometimes minimalism can seem
confusing as in Carl Andres famous brick
sculpture sometimes it can be stark like
a Mies van der or her office block but
sometimes as in the field of minimalist
music minimalism can be beautiful thanks
for watching don't forget to subscribe
and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon